liebes bundesheer liebe soldatinnen und
soldaten ich habe euch kennengelernt im
kosovo beim auslandseinsatz und am golan
und war total beeindruckt von eurer
leistung ich weiß 6000 von euch sind
unterwegs in sachen corona und arbeiten
für uns und ich danke euch an dieser
stelle recht recht herzlich ich war
selbst drei jahre lang als sportlerin
beim österreichischen bundesheer tätig
ich weiß wie diszipliniert ordentliches
da abgeht ich bin sehr stolz darauf dass
das bundesheer die derzeitige sehr
schwierige situation so toll manager vor
50 jahren war ich selbst beim
jagdkommandos trotz aller härte muss ich
sagen das was die heutigen soldatinnen
und soldaten im zusammenhang mit der
pandemie leisten das hat meine höchste
bewunderung
ich habe euch kennengelernt vor vier
jahre in kosovo wo ich für euch singen
haben dürfen und hab gesehen wie ihr
euch für den frieden einsetzen das war
großartig jetzt ist die gesundheits an
der reihe und er setzt euch wieder ein
für uns damit wir einfach wieder normal
hier leben können
die bewährte und in dem fall haben die
schüler 60 jahre alt die bevölkerung
weiß das zu schätzen was ihr da macht
das hier so hilfreich sein
im kampf gegen das gegen das virus
das ist toll was die ihm vom ankommen
mein gott werden in meinem alter hat man
schon so viel sondern biete sich ein
satz mit
es wird helfen und wird den kampf gehen
gibt ihnen hier werden wir werden den
gewinnern
ich war schon öfter beim test es tut
nicht weh es geht ganz schnell ist keine
große sache macht es einfach es zahlt
sich aus
ich bin selbst frisch getestet es ist
halb so schlimm und ich würde euch einen
fehlen euch testen zu lassen weil man
dann einfach komplett sicher sein kann
dass man momentan nicht infiziert ist
[Musik]